Black holes are the monsters of the universe,
terrifying cosmic beasts that devour all they
encounter. But black holes scare scientists
for very different reasons.
They challenge our theories to the breaking
point.
This is at the forefront of theoretical
physics.
When it comes to the detailed nature of black
holes.
It would not surprise me if we got it all
wrong.
The science of black holes is so challenging
that some scientists question whether they
exist at all.
Despite their fearsome reputation.
We've never actually seen one.
Black holes are everywhere.
They're all over the universe.
They're all throughout our galaxy.
But that doesn't mean that they're easy to
find.
They're black and space is black.
And black on black is kind of hard to see in
a picture of space.
This is paradoxical because scientists
believe black holes are born and some of the
brightest explosions in the universe.
Rising from the corpses of detonated stars
many times larger than our sun.
The star that burns for 10 million years
collapses to form a black hole in a period of
seconds.
As it collapses, the outer region of the star
hits the core, triggering a huge explosion, a
supernova. We see the bang, but not what's
left
behind. A dead core with the enormous mass
of the star crushed down into an
infinitesimal, tiny area.
From this minuscule high mass core.
A black hole is born.
The flow of gravity is so strong that nothing
can escape.
Not even light.
But how can scientists claim that black holes
exist if we can't even see them?
You could say that about the existence of the
atom.
We knew they had existed for decades,
centuries before.
We had actually seen one in some sort of
imaging device.
And so it's the same sort of thing with
black holes.
Just because you can't see it doesn't mean
it's not there.
Not seeing black holes, but knowing they're
there is a possibility, just like we know
that wind is there even though we can't see
air.
Air is invisible, but when the wind blows,
its effects can be measured.
It's the same with black holes.
You just need to know what to look for.
Black holes are gravitational giants of the
universe.
But we found only circumstantial evidence
that they exist to make it a slam dunk.
Cosmologists are listening for proof in the
hidden world of gravitational waves.
There are gravitational waves going through
this room all the time.
Every time I move my hands like I just did.
I create gravitational waves.
The problem is gravity is so weak that you
don't detect those gravitational waves.
In order to detect those disturbances in
space and time, you have to have cataclysmic
events involving massive objects.
Black holes are some of the densest objects
in the universe.
So we should be able to hear and measure the
waves created when they collide.
Legault The long interferometry
gravitational wave observatory, listens for
waves that can come from over a billion
light years away.
In 2017, Legault heard an enormous crash.
Two very massive objects collided at near the
speed of light.
And one of the most energetic events that we
have ever witnessed in the history of
humankind.
Two ultra heavy, ultra dense objects whirl
around each other, hurling powerful
gravitational waves through space.
The closer they fall toward each other, the
more gravitational energy they throw out.
Finally they collide in one of the most
violent events in the universe.
The smash sends out immense gravitational
waves that ripple across intergalactic space
until eventually Legault detects them.
Listening to a gravitational wave is like
listening to a musical instrument.
If it's making certain tones or certain
vibrations, you can figure out the size of
the musical instrument, the type of the
musical instrument.
Who's playing the musical instrument?
The thing that's really amazing about the
Lego detection is it allowed us to measure
the mass of these objects and how quickly
they coalesce together.
So we actually have an idea how dense they
must have been.
And with modern physics, we say, well, it
has to be a black hole.
But the question is, have we missed
something?
The information gathered by Legault is
groundbreaking.
But some scientists think that the
gravitational waves could have come not from
black holes, but from something even more
mysterious.
It's possible that what we identify as black
holes in our universe are really another
object like Gravity Star.
Possible. There's a capital P on that
possibility.
I grab a star is what scientists call an
exotic, compact object.
This bizarre theoretical body has exactly
the same mass and gravitational pull as a
black hole. But it's made of exotic matter.
A gravel star would be impossible to see
with the naked eye, but because it forms
differently than a black hole, it has a
strange, incredibly dense surface.
In the formation of what we think of as the
black hole, the catastrophic gravitational
collapse of a dense object.
Maybe it doesn't go all the way down to
become an infinitely dense point.
Instead, maybe there's some interaction that
prevents the formation of the black hole, and
instead you have a tight little dense ball,
which is what we call a gravity star.
So the Lego data could be the signature of
two black holes colliding, but it also could
be the signature of two gravest stars
colliding.
Right now, we can't tell them apart.
So for now, gravitational waves have led to a
dead end in the hunt for black holes.
We can't be completely sure that we're
hearing them and we already know we can't see
them. But what about the mayhem they leave
behind?
Even though you can't see the black hole
itself, it's going to leave behind a trail of
destruction. And that is something you can
see.
You. By picking apart a cosmic crime scene,
can scientists finally solve the mystery of
black holes?